the 70s are filled with oh let's just
try it
and in this crazy kind of way like it's
true the Brady the Brady The Brady Bunch
which has been had been off the air for
like five years and someone said what if
they had a variety show and we dressed
them all kind of like Evel Knievel like
in jumpsuits right and we put them in a
science giant Sound Stage with a
Olympic-sized swimming pool
and uh we got a bunch of uh synchronized
swimmers women as synchronized swimmers
to do Esther Williams stuff from the
1940s right and we'll have them all sing
songs and dance
you mean the kids from The Brady Bunch
know how to sing songs and dance no God
no idea that's not important it's
Plum won't do it she says it compromises
her because just get another blonde lady
they did they replaced Eve plum
Hill daughter and they got a different
person to play her and they never
addressed
no I don't know why she wouldn't do it I
think it's a time she thought she heard
Olympic-sized pool and she said this
probably doesn't sound good if they had
come to her like three years later she'd
have said where do I sign but uh it was
just it was just a crazy time I went out
to dinner last night and no and our
waitress
um was uh raised on a houseboat and I
said oh like Quincy and the the Blank
Stare that she gave me you know Quincy
me yeah that's the problem there's a
generational Gap do you not know who
Quincy is I don't know who Jack Blackman
played oh Jack Klugman do you know Jack
Klugman no do you know The Odd Couple
yeah we're talking about human lives
yeah I don't know what you're doing
that's Quincy
go about a medical examiner he's played
by Jack Klugman and it was kind of a big
show huge and and he lived on it to give
him some color they had him live on a
houseboat he was a ladies man and he was
a ladies man okay he was a ladies man
but my medical exam my favorite I saw a
trailer once for a Quincy episode this
in real time in the late 70s and
they said and tune in tonight you know
Quincy goes to the track for some fun
and it shows the horse racing and it
shows the actor who plays Quincy Jack
Clement going go go go when the horse
goes down and you see the horse collapse
and you see like literally Hooves in the
air and then they say
um uh they uh Quincy they just have a
shot of Quincy and he's looking down at
the horse and he looks up dramatically
and he went this horse was murdered
it was like 1980 and I was jumping up
and down in front of my TV set this
horse was murdered but that's one of the
shows that what was the show you did uh
with uh with uh Adam West it was uh look
well yeah look well Robert smack when I
did a pilot for Adam West called look
well about uh uh like a and then and
Quincy was one like Banacek Quincy uh
all those shows Mannix were like they
were part of what inspired you yes there
were a guy who doesn't play by the rules
yeah
come on yeah but he's like in part of
the system he does it no no yeah
and also they're always people are
always saying to him Quincy come on it
was a clear heart attack no it wasn't
and I'll prove it and then he goes
rushing off and um it's so much go on
YouTube and look at these Quincy clubs
there's one okay
[Laughter]
put the kids to sleep early
but you know what you would like to my
kids you know what you would like and
then we'll move on to more prosperous
areas but I swear to God there's a clip
out there there's an episode where uh
Quincy encounters the phenomenon of like
punk music and punk dancing and
something bad happens to somebody and no
I'm not kidding they actually tried to
recreate it but it's like 1970s TV
writers conception of and it's the band
is like yelling death death murder hate
and Quincy's in the audience going
what's happening
what's wrong this song was murdered his
song was murdered we're doing Cole
Porter right it's like when Elizabeth
Berkeley on said brother Bell got
addicted to uh caffeine oh yeah yeah
like that kind of like see now you're
edging up into territory now I know
trying to bring it bring it up a little
bit thank you it reminds me of the time
Big Time Rush made that movie
where they went to London and the bad
guys tried to get them did I went now I
went too far into it too I know who Big
Time Rush is but I don't know what movie
you're talking about it's it's good to
know about everything so now my kids
don't know any of the stars that I know
or or think well that's what I'm what's
interesting to me is like in your books
you're touching on all these characters
that I know and then I think I don't
know uh and and I you know I grew up
I grew up knowing about stuff in the 50s
60s 70s you know
um and you know once you're once it's
happening in your lifetime you know it
but sometimes I get the suspicion that
now a lot of kids don't know about
anything that happened before them is
that just me being a cranky old guy I
think that might be you being a little
bit of a I mean people know older things
but the things that you know or like
shows that ran for one season that no
one else talks about Quincy was it
Quincy was a huge show Quincy was big
yeah was it guys yeah Quincy was a big
show it was a huge show but there was
also like three channels that's true
everyone it was a different time and
Quincy was so big it was on all three
channels
simulcast but but the opposite's also
true I don't know what it is what it's
like with um your kids but my kids know
people that I have no idea what they're
talking you know when you go to the the
CVS or whatever in like a magazine cover
and I'm like I have no idea who they're
30. you know what I don't know who any
of them that's reality television but I
think because a lot of it is you know
Jen it tells Kristen she better back off
because you know Nico is hers and it's
something from below deck the underwater
series whatever and I don't know what
any of it is that's a really good job
someone doesn't know who I am and she's
still figuring it out
yeah who are you again uh yeah I think
it's funny because I was wondering these
books must be a nice
because your day job I would think it's
very intense yeah and then so you spend
a day talking about uh is this is the is
the system that was constructed 240
years ago possibly crumbling and then
it's okay you can go home now and maybe
it's fun to go into a room and be these
imaginary people that live in a
different time yep and just uh yes and
during
um yeah during this political era it's
nice to run away from it all although
there's a lot of obviously there's a lot
of resonance for what is going on today
in this book because the two plus so
it's Ike and Lucy tell the story their
brother and sister Ike is with Evel
Knievel in Montana and that is that
becomes like kind of a plot about
um demagogues and people who follow
demagogues like why would you follow
like Evil Knievel decides he's going to
run for president kind of like a
publicity stunt and he and his and this
gang of people who are living in the
woods of Montana start including like
start following him to watch Washington
DC
to raise hell and so that was a way to
kind of explore that topic and then Lucy
is working for a brand new tabloid in
Washington DC called the Washington
Sentinel which is being started by a
British media magnate named Max Lyon who
was very obviously Loosely based on
Rupert Murdoch so in the book you
originally called him goobert gerdoc
you saw an early draft and then your
lawyers got involved
gerdock hello Mike
I'd have never heard your Australian
accent oh is that Australian I thought
that was fantastic that's not a knife
this is annoyed but no but 77 do you get
into any Star Wars in there Star Wars is
mentioned it's mentioned at the
beginning just checking due diligence
yeah no I can uh I can Rachel the girl
he's in love with uh reference uh going
to see Star Wars also the a film that
I'm sure you're familiar with called
tentative tentacles have you heard of
tentacles one of them aliens uh Jaws
knockoffs oh okay horrible movie starred
Henry Fonda like it has all these huge
actors
um it's about a giant octopus I imagined
and um what you might not know is that
uh octopus octopi don't even have
tentacles they have arms so it wasn't
even named correctly why
why what why everything well it was just
again this is called the late 70s yes
and that summer of 77 I remember really
well because I I was and am a huge Elvis
fan and that's the summer that Elvis
died which is also a plot point in the
book and the big Caravan of Evel Knievel
they stop at Graceland and mourn Elvis
uh and then he jumps over the casket
and crashes
Graceland by the way at the time was not
a museum it was just where he lived
that's where he lived yeah yeah
um yeah my house is now a museum even
before I go really yeah
everyone it's like when you go to a room
to room and you push a button it's me
there this is where I read the paper
have you ever been in Graceland oh yeah
it's like the White House surprisingly
small
yeah it is uh very small I mean you can
imagine when Elvis got Graceland and
he's like 20 right and he buys this
house it he couldn't imagine a bigger
home and then all these years later now
that we live in this era of like
mcmansions and have people being in big
spaces Graceland is like oh this is cozy
it's nothing like cone land no which
I've been to I'm gonna build a cone land
yeah I'm gonna build it I mean it is
quite nice I'm sure it's going to be in
the Smoky Mountains have they all been
to Conan uh you've been to Cone land
many times yeah really yeah yeah you
both have been to my home yeah yeah yeah
yeah of course and there are a few times
you don't even know it
I saw you the camera caught you once
I wanted that though
is beautiful uh uh yeah
large it's a big tourist attraction I'm
the only guy that is trying to get this
the celebrity star bus to go by I'm like
waving them in you're like you know
hello actually you send out uh Sona to
give Maps I do yeah to the to the map
people and it's just your house right or
sometimes I'm just say I just say I'm
Adam Sandler's house and then from
behind the Hedgehog
by the way he killed it um he killed at
the at the Sandler Mark Twain award you
did a great job it was fun it was a
really fun night Conan did a great job
he definitely put a lot of work into it
in a good way I mean yeah you got it we
got to prepare you got to prepare it's
the way I prepare for these things but
I'm just saying Mr Tipper
all the demons
are here